hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his poem on the nature of things
lucretius is going to repeat a
maxim coming down all the way from
epicurus
death is nothing to us in latin nihil
iguitoremors
estadnos and he follows that up as well
by saying
pertinet
so
you know literally
from these things or there for
death is for us nothing nihil
it is it doesn't have being at all
nor does it pertain nor does it apply
nor
does it have any sort of value not even
a little bit that's the gila i'm a
trifle right and so this is a rather
bold declaration and he's going to
provide us with some argument for that
he's already considered
how it is that the mind and the spirit
are not immortal as some people have
claimed in other philosophical schools
or in religions
for better or for worse and then he's
going to say
uh here are some other considerations
to ease your mind because the ultimate
goal of this is to
have a
happy contented
life so he begins by saying that
you know when you die
there's there's really nothing
left to the mind or the spirit as he
puts it torn
from the body you only have a mind or a
spirit uh a anamos or onoma and these
are interconnected themselves
when you actually have a living
body
so he says
in days of old we felt no worry when the
hosts of carthage poured into battle on
every side
so when we shall be no more when the
union
of body and spirit that engenders us
that's what we are
has been disrupted to us who shall be
nothing
nothing by any hazard
will happen anymore
at all nothing will have the power to
stir our senses
not through earth
not though earth be fused with sea and
sea with sky and he says if any feeling
remains in the mind or the spirit after
it's been torn from our body
that is
nothing to us this word nothing is
coming up an awful lot in this why
because we are brought into being
by the marriage by the binding of body
and spirit that is literally
what we are and so he goes on he says
even if the matter that composes us
should be reassembled by time after our
death and brought back into its present
state if the light of life were given to
us
anew so like imagine something like
being brought into being
once again from some pattern that was
stored somewhere he says even that
contingency would be no concern of ours
once the chain of our identity had been
snapped that's a different person it's
sort of like the old teleporters in the
star trek thing it's not really you
that's being reconstituted it's it's a
different
thing that that's like you there isn't
any you
anymore so you don't have to worry about
that he's saying
he goes on further and he says
there is no existence there is no being
of a you
after your death who is going to
suffer right he says we who are now are
not concerned with ourselves in any
previous existence you don't remember it
you don't know about it it may as well
not even exist even if it you know if
there was any previous existence and he
says when you look at the immeasurable
extent of time gone by and the
multi-form movements of matter you'll
credit that these same atoms that
compose us must have been in many many
other combinations before now there's
really nothing special about the current
configuration
that is us and there isn't any
dead self
to suffer to
worry about things to be
bothered
by anything he says
if the future holds misery and anguish
in store
you gotta have a self the self has to be
in existence so you really only can
suffer in
this life this is the only life
according to lucretius and epicurus
this is the only place you can actually
have any suffering so he says
when the time comes
the self must be in existence in order
to be miserable
but from this fate we are redeemed by
death which denies existence or being to
the self that might have suffered these
tribulations and you know this goes back
to epicurus saying you don't need to
worry about death because
when death is here for you there isn't
any you for the death to be
here for you're dead there's no there's
no you anymore and then he goes on and
he says something really quite
psychologically astute he says well you
know people do project ahead to their
own death and they get quite upset when
they think about the things that might
be happening say to their body
or their stuff or their good reputation
and what are they actually doing in
those cases they are sort of
imaginatively projecting themselves into
a time when by definition they do not
exist so they're imagining in the
present
what the future
without them
but with them in a certain way is going
to look like so he says when you find a
person treating it as a grievance that
after death they were well either mulder
in the grave or fall afraid of flames or
the jaws of predatory beasts
be sure his utterance does not ring true
his heart is stabbed by a secret dread
however loudly the man himself may
disavow the belief that after death he
will still experience sensation i i'm
not i'm convinced he does not grant the
admission he professes so if he really
understood things he wouldn't be worried
about that sort of matter
so this is the sort of standard
epicurean
view
he also has a really interesting
argument about death and sleep
this might actually be a reference back
to
plato's apology where socrates
argues uh that death isn't going to be
so bad because one of the possibilities
is it's like the best sleep you've ever
had in your life you you know you're so
rested nothing disturbs you and lucretia
says
yeah so think about sleep right when you
are
sleeping what happens he says you are at
peace now in the sleep of death and so
you'll stay till the end of time pain
and sorrow will never touch you again
but to us of course we're
affected by that we feel
bad about that but he says
even in sleep when mind and body alike
are at rest no one misses himself
nobody's like oh i wish i was around
right but now i'm asleep unfortunately
or size for life if such sleep he says
we're prolonged to eternity
no longing for ourselves would trouble
us because we'd be unconscious right and
he goes so far as to say that sleep is
kind of like a nothingness right it's uh
you could say almost a lack of being and
then he says what's death death
therefore must be regarded as far as we
are concerned as having even less and it
depends on how you want to translate
existence
or being
than sleep which is in a certain sense a
nothing so you've got almost you know
you can't actually have less than
nothing but he's using that as a figure
of speech here this is sort of what we
call an a fortiori argument where you
say listen this is the case and over
here that's going to be even more the
case so you know what is death to us
literally nothing or even less than
nothing he says
death is followed by a far greater
dispersal of the seething mass of matter
once that break in life is intervened
there is no more waking period
so you're not even sleeping in death
you're just
there is no you
death kind of doesn't exist
and then the most interesting feature
about this i kind of think is that he
has nature
respond
sort of you know as if nature was
personified
he says suppose nature were to suddenly
find a voice and round upon one of us in
these terms and say what is your your
grievance what's your problem man why
why are you bitching and whining
about this why do you give yourself up
to this whining and repining why do you
weep and wail over death and so nature's
going to introduce a couple
considerations
the first one is hey if life has been
pleasant to you so far
then you should just be like happy that
you enjoyed it
sort of like a guest at a banquet you
know you go to a dinner party and you
have wonderful drinks and conversation
and awesome food and the dessert comes
and now the coffee and the the hosts are
kind of looking at you like uh okay uh
let's let's get our ubers let's get our
taxis let's get our cars let's get out
of here right and it's time for you to
go do you sit around and say can't we
have some more courses oh this was so
wonderful no get your
your butt out of your chair and head out
the door you're like a decent guest she
says
why don't you retire like a dinner guest
who's eaten his fill of life
and take your carefree rest with a quiet
mind if it's been good for you
cool
now you've had your share right
if the things were bad on the other hand
why the hell do you want more of that
that's not going to do you any good she
says um
if all your gains have been poured
profitless away and life has grown
distasteful
why do you seek to swell the total if
things have become irritating
distasteful boring for you
don't keep on going on with it you know
the new
she says can but turn out as badly as
the old and perish as unprofitably why
not rather make an end of life
and
trouble right
she also talks about people who
have been around for quite a while you
know she says
you're withering away withering now
after tasting all the joys of life but
you're always pining for what is not
and unappreciative of the things at hand
and because of that your life is slipped
away unfulfilled and unprized death has
stolen upon you unawares before you're
ready to retire
from life's banquet filled and satisfied
and she says
that's not befitting you know why
you need to get out of the way
so
new lives can come in and enjoy the same
stuff that you have don't be selfish
she goes on and says um
compose your mind to make way for others
other beings
this is very interesting other beings
need that matter that you're composed of
to make themselves to have their own
lives get out of the way retire this is
the natural
order of things just cooperate with it
instead of you know getting all upset
about it she goes on as well and uh
actually there is one line here there is
need of matter so that later generations
may arise when they've lived out their
span
they will follow you by gone generations
have taken your road those to come will
take it no
less so you yourself have already
benefited from other people dying and
getting out of the way and making their
matter available to you
do the same thing now
he also brings up another concern that
people have i'm going to be punished in
the afterlife like all these stories
that i've heard about there's going to
be suffering
and
he goes on he says as for all those
torments that are said to take place in
the depths of acheron
where do we actually find them not in
some afterlife here and now
in our own lives and we don't need to go
over every example but let's look at a
few
there is no wretched tantalus tantalus
was tantalized for being a pretty bad
guy by being deprived of food and water
that was always just out of his grasp
down in hell right
and she says
he says in this life there really are
mortals oppressed by unfounded fear of
the gods and trembling at the impending
doom
you don't have to worry about that sort
of
thing right
he goes on as well
sisyphus 2 is alive for all the sea
where is sisyphus sisyphus is this
character who again bad guy gets
punished has to push the boulder up the
hill then it rolls down the other way
and lucretius is saying there's no
sisyphus in hell
sisyphus is right here and he's plural
and
you know he's not only men but also
women and everybody else
what is he doing bent on winning the
insignia of office its rods and ruthless
axes by the people's voice vote and is
embittered by perpetual defeat to strive
for this profitless and never granted
prize and in striving toil and moral
incessantly this is indeed to push a
boulder laboriously up a steep hill only
to see it once the top is reached
rolling and bounding down to the flat
levels of the plane so we make our own
hell here on earth by our
foolish ungoverned superstitious
pick whatever adjective you want desires
fears that we we are contributing to
things
a final consideration arguing for why
death is nothing to us
everybody dies
nobody
escapes it
he says here is something you might well
say to yourself from time to time
even good incus looked his last on the
daylight a better man than you my
presumptuous friend by a long reckoning
death has come to many another monarch
and potentate who ruled over mighty
nations so if political leaders they're
all going to die they all have died
except for the ones who are alive right
now and just give it a little bit of
time and they'll all be dead
and to it he says the discoverers of
truth and beauty
and the attendance of the muses among
them homer who in solitary glory bore
the scepter but is sunk into the same
slumber as the rest i mean homer's stuff
is still around cool hobart's dead
there isn't any homer anymore you're not
going to bother him because there isn't
any him to bother democritus when ripe
aged warned him the mindful motions of
his intellect were running down
made his unbowed head a willing
sacrifice to death and the master
himself is of course the master of
lucretius's school
when his daylight race was daylet race
was run epicurus himself died whose
genius outshone the race of men and dim
them all as the stars are dimmed by the
rising of the fiery sun and so here's
the payoff
you
why are you kicking and protesting
against your sentence you're you whose
life is next door to death although you
still live and look on the light you're
wasting a lot of your life you're not as
good as these people they died
why shouldn't you
why should you worry about death then
and he ends this book by talking about
this craving for life the attempts to
prolong life
he says this is kind of foolish
they deprive us of happiness and
tranquility they actually make us
miserable we're not using the time that
we have
well
to enjoy it instead we're worrying and
complaining
and all these negative things when if we
just reminded ourselves that death is
nothing to us
we could actually
live a happy existence in the time that
we have before we inevitably
die
you